each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
my name is Lee darks I'm the director
for education and scholarly
communications in the microsoft research
connections team and today I'm very
pleased to to have hazel asuncion from
University of Washington Bothell to join
us to give us a talk on automated
traceability techniques hazel is an
assistant professor at the computing and
software systems department at the
University of Washington Bothell she
received her PhD in information in
computer science at the University of
California Irvine where her research
emphasis was software traceability
further she has worked in industry in a
variety of roles as a software engineer
at unisys corporation and as a
traceability engineer at wonder where
corporation where she designed a
successful in-house traceability system
so what I'd like to do now is hand the
podium over to Hazel to talk to us about
automated traceability techniques in
software engineering and East science
hazel please well thank you all and
especially to leave for having me come
and talk about my research as Lee
mentioned I will be talking about
automated traceability techniques for
software engineering and science I'll
talk about the parallels that take place
in both fields and how the
cross-fertilization of ideas can benefit
both areas all right so more
specifically I will be talking about the
following topics I'll first introduce
you to the idea of traceability and why
it's important then i'll discuss
traceability challenges and this is in
context of my industry project at wonder
where i'll then move on and talk about
insights that i've gleaned from the area
of e science to address some of these
traceability challenges that endeavor
resulted in a practical approach to
software traceability called X and then
I'll move on and discuss how ax is
enhanced with the use of machine
learning technique called topic modeling
and then I'll wrap up the talk by
discussing how acts like techniques can
be applied to ISA
and supporting data provenance all right
so let's talk about traceability
envision a small software development
team where you have one person in charge
of each face of the software lifecycle
so one person is in charge of creating
the requirements document use cases
another person is in charge of creating
your structural design or state charts
the developer is in charge of coding and
make updating the wiki pages and finally
the QA engineer is in charge of creating
the test cases and maintaining the bug
database so let's say that the person in
charge of the requirements is interested
in finding the related documentation for
a particular requirement well it's easy
to see that that person can simply talk
to the rest of the team and ask them for
the related documentation now let's
think of a scenario where you have a
larger development organization and you
have multiple people working on each
phase of the software lifecycle now you
have teams of people working on each
phase and these teams have their own set
of tools and they maintain the
information in their own repositories
now it's more difficult to find the
related information across these
heterogeneous artifacts now let's raise
the level of complexity and let's talk
about a software development team that
is distributed across the globe and
let's say that parts of the system is
developed by another organization let's
say they're contracting a sub part of
the system now it becomes even more
difficult to find the related
information since the information is not
only geographically distributed but is
under different authority domains since
we have subcontractors involved now in
the picture so the goal of my research
is to be able to identify these related
information which may be distributed may
be heterogeneous and using explicit
links to identify these connection
thus far my research has been applied to
the field of software engineering but
the techniques that I've uncovered in
software engineering can also be applied
in other domains such as e-science or
domains with large digital records such
as medical patient files or patent
records in software engineering
specifically software traceability can
help us quickly access the related
information so if we are interested in
finding information on a particular
module in the system links to that
system can answer questions like why
this particular component is used if it
could be replaced who are the people who
wrote this particular module is this
component tested and does it meet
requirements in addition traceability
aids in understanding the entire system
in understanding the impact of changes
to the system and debugging the system
and in communication between various
stakeholders in East science if we
captured traceability links between the
design and the various artifacts as
represented by the blue lines then it
will help us in understanding the
rationale behind the experiment that is
referred to as data provenance it will
also help us in tracking the past
experiments that have been performed the
related data sets and the resulting
publications so in the entire self
experiment lifecycle so now I move on to
talk about some of the challenges in
being able to capture these traceability
links and this section is in the context
of my industry workout wonder where this
work is in collaboration with frederic
francois and our Richard and Taylor so a
quick background on the context of this
work I did this work at wonder where
which is based in Lake Forest California
and the company is a leading supplier of
industrial automation software they
have a distributed development setting
where they have developers in the US
Australia Europe Middle East Africa and
India at the time of the project there
were more than 40 projects going in
parallel and they had 250 development
employees the company was interested in
two types of traceability requirements
traceability and process traceability
what's requirements traceability well
essentially it's mapping the different
artifacts produced to the requirements
to ensure that those artifacts satisfy
the customer requirements process
traceability meanwhile is mapping the
actual processes the day-to-day tasks to
company procedures to make sure that
these processes conform to the company
procedures the Wonderware was interested
in both types of traceability to comply
with government regulations they have
customers food and pharmaceutical
companies who have to abide by
government regulations thus the software
that runs in their plants have to buy by
these regulations as well in addition
some of their big customers require
audits on their development process and
thus process traceability was needed
finally they also needed to manage their
projects more efficiently the company
needed an end-to-end traceability but as
I will discuss traceability is a hard
problem why it requires a lot of manual
intervention and there are many research
approaches but these are rarely adopted
in practice simply because they're not
feasible here's an overall picture of
the challenges that wonder where there's
a high cost to the commercial tool that
they were using at the time it was an
off-the-shelf tool and even though it
was expensive it still wasn't meeting
the needs of the company the development
team had to enter data redundantly into
different tools this resulted in
document obsolescence because you update
one file but the other files are not
updated so you have documents getting
obsolete at the same
time documents are inconsistent all
because they were using heterogeneous
tools the team was also using some ad
hoc workarounds just to try to get the
files together as I said they have
distributed development so artifacts are
distributed that makes it difficult to
access the artifacts if you are outside
the groups you have remote users which
makes it more difficult coordination is
difficult and so project managers had to
manually track their projects analyzing
these problems I saw that these are
mirror economic technical and social
perspectives and thus to address the
traceability challenges we have to
address all these perspectives at once
all right so we developed an in-house
traceability tool and we use these key
design decisions at the top is
minimizing cost that was a key concern
of the company we minimized costs by
using by developing this traceability
tool on top of existing tools that the
company already use so we didn't have to
go out and buy new software we also
designed the software to be intuitive so
minimize training time we bounded the
problem space what that is is we just
identified what are the key artifacts
key information that we need to trace
across the organization we supported
existing work practices we didn't want
to drastically change what the people
were doing because we want all of them
to buy into our tool we want them to use
our tool in order for us to achieve
enter entries ability we entered
interpret information once by
centralizing information into
repositories so the project management
group have their own repository the
architect group has their own repository
the QA group has their own repository
and all their information is being fed
into this repository that information is
then displayed into the different tools
that they're using so we're documents
Excel spreadsheet so what not and
finally we identified the limits of
automation we identified which are the
priority items to be automated and found
that there are some mappings between
artifacts that's difficult to automate
simply because there's no textual
similarity has to be user identified so
the results of this study or work show
that the time spent in performing the
traceability tasks were cut in half they
needed less people to maintain this tool
it was easier to maintain their they had
a low cost of deployment and at the time
this was reported it was running
successfully for over a year it was
successful such that all the active
projects of the company have were
migrated into this in-house trace tool
the architect group liked the tool it
was easy to use minimal training
required and it also helps them in their
high level design tasks I'm just really
quickly we just wanted to show you the
model that we followed these are the
artifacts that we've selected to trace
marketing requirements use cases
functional wrecks and test cases these
map to specific software development
lifecycle phases indicated by the dotted
lines we provided workflow support we
identified who the key users are these
are the producers of trace information
and these without the boxes are the
consumers of trace information it was
important for us to mainly cater to the
needs of the producers of trace
information because they are doing most
of the work of entering the information
here's our tool design we have a
back-end database workflows supported by
SharePoint we use word macros to do a
bi-directional consistency between the
repository and the documents so it's all
automated they enter information into
the word document then the macros would
update the database if other people
enter information on that word document
again that's updated in the database so
the next time a user opens the word
document they can
the latest and greatest there's no
inconsistency and we use various you I
to access the the workflow support
here's a screenshot of the SharePoint
and how we provided workflow support
here's a high-level task manager use
case list that is subdivided into
subtasks that are independent of each
other these linked to specific windows
that help users perform that particular
task so what does this do well it raises
the visibility of the lifecycle tasks so
that there's more coordination within
the team and it helps also with working
with the remote groups because they can
see where the documents are there's a
central portal for them to go to all
right we also created automatically
generated reports with infopath for this
particular window it shows you
information being pulled from different
repositories so this information is
being pulled from the project management
repository this information is being
pulled from the architect repository and
this test results is being pulled from
the test group so and one window you can
see information that is owned by
different groups and they like this very
much because now they can trace they can
see the artifacts across the different
groups and the different groups can
access the same information all right so
that result was good it worked well for
that one setting but I want to define a
more generalizable answer to software
traceability challenges that's why I
looked at the domain of the science to
look get possible insights as I studied
the domain of e science and data
Providence in particular I found some
parallels between the two fields so
these this chart just tells the
traces and software traceability is
analogous to Providence lineage data
pedigree in E science as far as item
being traced there's a lot of
heterogeneous
files in both fields so with the
metadata for data provenance might want
to trace email research papers in
software engineering you might want to
trace requirements documents wiki pages
code so all heterogeneous files and in
both domains there's a context on which
the tracing occurs it could be during an
experiment run or a software project and
then there's the bigger context which is
the organization and then there's the
domain on which that particular
provenance is being applied to maybe
it's physics maybe it's biology whereas
in software traceability there's a
domain of application is it the medical
field is it the government related
software also there are similar
challenges for both fields there's the
concern of overhead so when you're
capturing Providence you start thinking
about what is the cost of storage
overhead for that captured metadata in
addition you start thinking and also
about what is the training time for
these researchers to learn this
providence tool in software traceability
I mentioned the overhead of capturing
these links and maintaining the
traceability links and learning the
traceability tool another challenge is
the lack of interoperability between the
tools that are being used in both
domains so in a science there are
different data provenance systems but
they don't talk to each other so the
provenance captured in one tool can't be
exported over to the other tool same
thing in software engineering
information entered in one tool is hard
to translate over to another tool so
they have to do manually you know data
entry incompatibilities occur in both
fields so you have incompatible data
types any science and different data
types in in software also different
perspectives in a science you might have
a big research group each one has their
own perspective different expertise so
they're coming into the project with
different perspectives same thing in
software trace
ability a software development team has
an Allen analyst you have a developer QA
engineer all of them are looking at the
data from different perspectives so we
have to cater to these different
perspectives it was interesting for me
when when i was doing this study back in
two thousand seven when i came across
this life cycle of an in silico
experiment experiment conducted using
computers i thought hey look at that you
have phases that are similar to the
software life cycle you have a design
phase you have an experiment running
phase which is kind of like
implementation or testing and then you
have the experiment publication which is
somewhat similar to the deployment of
software so i thought that was
interesting when i was doing this study
again back in 2007 these were the main
systems that i encountered I categorized
them into different levels we have
systems at the operating system level
that simply capture Providence by
capturing operating system level events
such as file open file closed file edit
and so on then at the highest level we
have workflows like Kepler taverna
Mistral's and so on that capture
provenance based on the experiment
design so when you look at the
provenance it's easier to understand
what's going on just some of the
summaries of the insights that I've
gleaned from data provenance the
provenance of data is intertwined with
the provenance of process what does that
mean that means is the history of data
is intertwined with what actually
happened during the experiment what are
the functions that were applied to this
particular data set the second bullet
says that Providence collection is take
holder centric what that means is the
researcher who is running the experiment
has the ability to determine how often
they will collect provenance
at what level of granularity who they
will publish it to and so on and that
was a big idea for me to transfer over
to software traceability because usually
in software engineering software
traceability is not stakeholder centric
it's more management centric where the
management says you trace these
artifacts the third level is automated
provenance capture has its limits what
this means is that the framework on
which providence is being automatically
captured determines the level of
semantics of the provenance so if you
have a tool that captures operating
system level events then the level of
semantics is just there at the operating
system level of events but if you have a
framework that captures the experiment
level then you have an understanding of
what actually happened during the
experiment finally a technique called
reasoner's was used in automatically
inferring relationships so you might
have data sets that are indirectly
related and these reasoner's can tell
you okay how there's a new relationship
that takes place between these data sets
so all these insights were used to
inform my software traceability
technique which I will now talk about
all right and this was my PhD thesis
okay so X what does ax stand for its
architecture eccentric traceability for
stakeholders what this means is it
focuses the links on the architecture so
capture the links through the
architecture it's for stakeholders so we
allow users to choose what kinds of
information they're interested to link
to finally we provide mechanisms for
capturing filtering visualizing and
analyzing the links if we go back
remember the traceability challenges we
encountered at wonder where economic
technical and social acts is a technical
approach that considers the economic and
the social perspectives and that will
become more clear
say I go on all right here's a model of
my approach at the center is the
architecture the cones represent
different perspectives so we have the
architect perspective developer
perspective field engineering QA
perspective each perspective is only
interested in capturing links to certain
artifacts so for example an architect
may only be interested in linking
requirements to design that's it so that
they're free to do that and that's
indicated by the dotted lines now a
developer may only be interested in
capturing links between code and the
design that's fine and what we can do
once we captured all these links is we
can aggregate them so you can have a
project-based link that is complete and
accessible to the different members of
the development team all right now I'll
move on to the mechanisms of our
approach and I'll go through each of
these mechanisms in the next slides so
the first one is we capture links
prospectively this idea was borrowed
from e-science because i watch how or i
read how provenance systems would record
the actual experiment run based on the
workflow so hey we can borrow that
recording put that over to software
traceability and help us link together
heterogeneous information so the idea is
we have users click on a record button
and in the background links are
automatically created this allows us to
capture contextual and temporal
relationships that would have been
otherwise lost if we didn't capture
these interactions this allows us to
read a link to read access artifacts and
also to link incrementally so users
don't have to do all the linking all at
once they can simply click the record
button whenever they do their work
linking would take place in the
background turn it off the next
they do the same thing and then you can
build up your base of links over time so
it's incrementally done here's a
scenario that a person might follow so
let's say that an architect is visiting
a particular component and then proceeds
to open these other files like email
white paper mock-up in the background
links would be created when the
recording is turned on so you might
wonder well if they're just following
the user actions how does it know which
artifact to link to well that's that's
where the rules come in these are user
customized you might think of it as
policies and these rules the ideas
borrowed from reasoner's in a science
these rules are the ones that filter our
weed through the user interactions so it
can check okay the user is not
interested in linking to powerpoint
files we won't link to any of the
powerpoint files that they visited and
these rules can also check on the
patterns of events or time of access or
primary trace artifact to create these
links in addition these rules can add
link semantics or information about why
this particular link is important the
next thing is being able to cross the
tool boundary crossing the tool boundary
is an important thing because we
encounter heterogeneous files for this
these insights were borrowed from the
area of open hypermedia so two things we
have first class and airy links and
adapters ok so we treat links as first
class objects what that means is we can
manipulate these links we can store
these links on their own thus we can
have n this destination instead of to
destination that is often and on the web
you have two destinations we can also
then link to read only artifacts as I
said the second idea is having these
adapters ok these adapters are tools
specific so you create an adapter for
particular tool and the we have two
specialized adapters are recording anna
rendering adapter now a recording
adapter is the one that keeps track of
the user actions it creates a log of the
actions on the data the rendering
adapter is the one that is in charge of
displaying a specific data within that
tool at that particular location so
let's say that you link to page five
hundred in word doc X the rendering
adapter will open to page five hundred
on that word docx so you don't have to
go through the different pages finding
the specific location that you want to
link to here's a visual of how it might
also work so let's say that you have the
architecture and you are interested in
looking at the rationale for why this
module was created the way it was and
there's a link to a video recording of
the meeting of the team so if you have
an adapter a rendering adapter and it
knows the specific location within the
video you can have the adapter simply
fast forward to that location and start
playing at that specific location you
can do other things with the other tools
so for example if you are linking to a
word document you can have the tools
simply look for a particular search term
and have it display at that first
occurrence of that search term all right
now move on to visualizing the link
information using mashups so mashups are
popularly used today to aggregate
information from different sources on
the web so we get that idea and we
aggregate the linked information to
provide real-time status okay here's an
example of a mash-up again here's the
architectural design for art studio 4
and the different components are
color-coded the outlines are color-coded
so those that are that have a yellow
outline like
this are those other ones are the
components with bugs and the components
that have not been implemented are
outlined in red like that one at the top
there's this one here at the bottom now
if you zoom in and take oh and select
that particular component that has a
related bug you can click on it it will
display the list of Link's which right
there at the top right and when you
visit that link it will bring you to the
bug tracking database to show you the
particular bug that it was associated
with all right well that's X now we're
moving on to how we enhance acts with
topic modeling this is in collaboration
with my brother Arthur ascencion and my
PhD adviser Richard Taylor okay so let
me introduce you to the idea of topic
modeling you have a text corpus and you
can feed that into a topic learning
algorithm after it goes through the
topic learning algorithm outcomes
automatically discovered topics at the
top and documents that are tagged by by
those topics so if you look closely at
this particular example each of the
lines at the top there represent a topic
and the words are the highest
probability words that represent that
particular topic now these are two New
York Times articles that were taken I
think this analysis was done on a period
of a month of all the New York Times
articles and we can see on the first
snippet of it has mostly red and maroon
topics now if we look at our legend up
there we can see that the maroon and red
topics represent the September 11th
attacks okay if we look at the blue
topics we see that it is related to the
business topic
so this makes sense for the first
article because if you read the article
it's talking about the effects of the
September 11 attacks on business so you
have those two topics here on the lower
article snippet we see mostly green and
light green topics now when we look at
the are topics discovered we see that
those are big sports topics and that
makes sense when we read the article
because it's talking about a specific
football game all right so how does a
more more details on the topic modeling
we use a particular topic model called
latent dershlit occasion and as I said a
topic is represented as a probability
distribution over words and a document
is modeled as a probability distribution
over topics so we can have autumn a
automated analysis on the documents we
can find out exactly what the document
means by certain simply running this
topic modeling so how does topic
modeling help x well ax or prospective
traceability as you capture more and
more links you increase your artifact
base and you have more varied types of
artifacts when you have that it
increases your topic quality because
topic modeling works on large large data
sets okay topic modeling helps ax or
prospective traceability because it can
automatically identify the topical
content of the documents so it can aid
the prospective capture instead of
floundering around the search results
you can actually intelligently navigate
to the documents that you're interested
in it also aids in the detection of
false positives so link quality goes up
so it's a win-win situation for both
techniques alright so here's an overview
of our approach we've developed three
tools
we have trace you have X and we have the
team I'll talk about each tool now so
trace is the topically rich artifacts
search engine it's somewhat similar to
Google only it's enhanced with topics so
you have a search term that you can
search for and the results are documents
with a matching search term in addition
to that you have the topics that have
been automatically discovered based on
that set of documents with that search
term and within each result you have the
topic distribution so you know what that
document contains so essentially this
guides in the prospective capture of
trace links see you have an
understanding of what these documents
contain you can also order by topic
distributions so if you were interested
in topic 2 then it will order the search
results again by the the closely related
distribution to topic 2 if we are
interested and in one particular
artifact and we want to find artifacts
that are similar to that particular
document we can simply click on similar
pages and it will show you documents
that have the similar topic distribution
so we have clusters we have documents
that are clustered together based on
similar topics serving as a
recommendation system all right so now
we show you the screenshot for our acts
tool or the tool that captures links
prospectively we can click on the start
recording select the archipelago and
perhaps visit one of these links when we
do that we stop the recording we get a
confirmation of which links were visited
and then they are added to the list of
links for that particular component
we now move on to the third tool which
is our visualization tool here's our
visualization tool called team or topic
enhance architecture mashup it shows you
the architecture and when you select a
topic on the left side of the screen it
highlights the sections of the system
that is related to that particular topic
so it gives you a bird's eye view of the
entire system when we zoom into one
particular component and selected we see
the list of links with their topic
distributions on the right side of the
screen and you can visit the links and
look at the artifacts based on the color
coding of the topics you can automatic
you know easily identify which ones are
false positive links alright so all that
to set the background for how we can
apply these techniques or acts like
techniques to e science again data
provenance simply means the origin and
history of data the most predominant
means of capturing data providence has
been scientific workflows so what are
the challenges to data provenance well
Jim Gray said that managing information
is now as necessity for scientists
whether it be data collection analysis
publication and retrieval and this
applies from small-scale research
projects to large-scale research
projects the challenge is it's it's
expensive to capture all the metadata
it's too laborious for scientists to
manually write down what's the setting
on the instrument what is the parameter
on this function what version of this
tool are we using and it's also
different difficult to collect
provenance across different tools and
data analysis takes
across heterogeneous tools so what is
the state of the art and metadata
capture well we can have researchers
manually annotate their experiment
design you can do that with Kepler we
could do that with a Taverna in the my
Grid project another approach is to
manually group the experiment related
objects together so what that means is
you simply upload to one folder online
all the publications da email what not
and that is supported by the my
experiment project another approach is
to use the idea of ontologies to
automatically linked the documents with
provenance logs now these ontologies
take time to build up because you have
to identify important concepts how they
are related to each other that's
supported within the my grid project
another suggestion by grey and is to
have the team use software tools so all
the communication is through the
software tools and then you can just
search through the electronic records so
you can like the Met Office which is
UK's National Weather Service they've
built this flexible configuration
management tool which is based on
open-source CM systems open-source bug
databases and with that in that setting
you can simply search through electronic
records what is the state of the art in
capturing provenance across different
tools well more recently they have this
open data interchange provenance
metadata they called it open provenance
model and the idea here is the different
provenance systems can export to this
standardized metadata so that the other
provenance systems can consume it so
that's a way to do data interchange
another means is to use a protocol that
allows for sharing and accessing data
across different tools and that's using
the open open data protocol for some
reason my my link got cut off my guesses
it was a leak online so this helps in
sharing the same data by using a
particular protocol and you can share it
to the to the other members of the team
still another approach is to chain
multiple workflows so if you have a big
research team each team is using a
particular workflow you can have the
different workflows that were produced
to be chained together so yeah you can
have a workflow created in taverna
workflow created in WHSV lamin another
workflow created in Kepler and you can
just link all those workflows together
that will represent a big overarching
experiment a final approach is to use a
centralized repository so essentially
you can have the workflow specifications
that are done in the different tools
translate them to prologue prologue is
your central repository and that keeps
track of your provenance what are the
issues with these well certainly these
are steps in the right direction but the
thing is they still require scientists
to adopt these specialized tools and
end-to-end provenance capture is not yet
achieved so you can do it within these
some limited limited tools what is my
goal my research goal is to support
scientists in the capture of data
providence within their existing work
environment and I call this NC too so
I'd like to use an approach that is a
lightweight means of capturing metadata
to capture metadata across different
tools and to capture these links to
metadata as scientists perform their
scientific analysis so capture in the
background
what's my research plan for this short
term I'd like to build a piecemeal
Providence support within popularly used
tools by scientists and this is
supporting the NC to capture why do I
want to do this well it'll minimize
training time so the scientists are
already familiar with the tool no
training time involved or very little
training time we minimize tool set up
and encourage wide adoption across the
different researchers I plan to build a
Providence link base to maintain and
store the different links to the
metadata i plan to aggregate and analyze
all the captured provenance using
machine learning techniques like topic
modeling and then to visualize these
captured links to serve as a metadata
for the experiment what's my long-term
plan I'd like to move towards supporting
large-scale science so investigating the
scalability of acts like techniques to
support collaborating scientists
investigating how i can use insights
from the research area of software
architecture to build a scalable tool
support and finally investigating the
scalability of topic modeling or other
machine learning techniques in analyzing
very very large-scale metadata as of
today though topic modeling can scale to
hundreds of thousands of artifacts quite
well so now i'll discuss my current and
planned projects the first one is the
provenance within Excel why Excel
scientists in the Natural Sciences use
Excel to analyze their data this is
evidenced by the number of books I just
googled how many books were geared to
scientists on how to use excel and
there's a whole bunch of them so yes
we're going to create an adapter for
Excel
an excel add-in and here's a screenshot
where I just had my students start
working on this one so on the right side
is the excel add-in and what you can do
with this is you open a file you select
the record button and we can track the
user actions on the interaction with the
data if we could switch to the video
that'd be great okay sure
alright so we'll quickly show you a
video clip on the excel add-in that
we've developed any stoppage know
whether it is gonna start it again sure
so back
so what we can see here is we are going
to select a data this happens to be a
data regarding the solar flux and we're
going to open this file then we'll see
on the screen the file that's been
opened then we can record once it's
recording it's tracking the user actions
on the data so we can track whether the
user is formatted the data highlighted
yellow highlighted at red and once we're
done manipulating the data we can click
on the stop record button and visualize
it the ideas this will come up as like a
workflow like visualization but at this
point it's simply a text file this will
be rendered as a box and arrow later on
that the intent there is to frequent
switch to the power go back to this
lines that may be the ID
they did with an Excel spreadsheet
represent that as a workflow not looking
at macro code edit the visualization
save it and that will translate into the
macro changes so that later on they can
rerun the same the modified workflow or
even share it to others and it's within
a small context but I think this is very
useful since a lot of like I said a lot
of scientists use Excel and very useful
for analyzing data within Excel tracking
Providence within Excel now another
project that I planned this is still in
the planning stages is to capture
Providence across different tools so I'm
planning to build adapters actually for
these tools Word PowerPoint adobe
acrobat i already have two adapters i
just need to improve them to gear them
towards e-science then i'd like to build
a tool adapter for Outlook or Microsoft
Exchange whatnot so that I can
incorporate metadata that is found in
email and word documents in published
papers PDFs and link them together
another plan project is to store these
provenance links in an SQL backend
database then this SQL database will
then interface with a visualization tool
which will be used to help the people
outside the science team to access this
metadata public students educators
whoever so those are ones that are
really close
to being worked on all right so I'll
wrap up the the talk with insights from
X what are the lessons that I've learned
based on the experience of implementing
tool support for X well links the
metadata can be captured within the
scientists work environment I think and
we do that by building these tools
specific adapters links to heterogeneous
metadata can be automatically captured
we can perhaps your provenance across
different tools and analyze them using
machine learning techniques like topic
modeling and then we can do
visualization so that we can support a
comprehensive understanding of the
scientific analysis I'd like to
acknowledge the undergraduate students
who helped in the development the first
two were the ones instrumental in doing
the excel add-in my current students at
univ offal these are the students that
UC Irvine who helped me develop the ax
tool I'm currently being funded at NIDA
Bothell and NSF was my source of funding
for the development of the ax research
any questions you're welcome I have okay
that's good probably don't want to talk
about offline definitely um you know one
of the one of the questions that I had
was just specific to a couple points you
made earlier on and then you kind of
hold them together with the program's
interface mhm is how do you envision
this being searchable and
at a lab level at an institution level
at a domain level Hunnam I guess in all
of you yeah yeah definitely all of the
above there may be depending on the
stakeholders involved there may be some
restrictions on you know what they want
to publish or you know but certainly I
can envision this being searchable at
the at the organization level you know
even including the public if they want
to use the search tool certainly I'm
thinking
I think about my experiment tool I'm not
familiar i'm familiar with the tool but
not familiar with this search I've been
looking the ability that had the
semantic connections across Provence or
across one was oh yeah currently I think
what they're using is building this
ontology great but like I said requires
time to build up an ontology with this
one we're trying to provide a
lightweight support so the users don't
have to spend so much time trying to set
things up we do the set up for them and
then they can start using it another
super practical question about for
instance the Excel idea where you're
recording stopping recording how
necessary is and I think you alluded
this earlier cantung how easy is it to
capture and start to finish and then
realize oh right in the middle of that I
went off on a little work and I did
something I didn't want to do or oh I
popped over went to face yeah Norah
phone rang Sharon how easy is it to go
back and edit edit capture or is it
necessary to redo the capture um the way
I envisioned this is it will be easy to
edit first of all any any digression to
other tools will not be recorded over
all of you only within Excel so that
eliminates then that in a particular
tool somebody was it answer trace it
would go across yes goes across tools
but for the excel add-in it would just
be within that tool yeah now if they
have a digression within Excel my
solution is simply record everything so
we will have a visualization of
everything that they've done and they
can look at the visualization say oh I
don't mean this particular step right
click delete so that that would be
eliminated from the captured provenance
they can save it and when they save it
that would be automatically translated
to the macro by you know the translated
macro level so that later on they can
rerun the edited workflow
more practical questions share literally
you're right now you're capturing as a
text file exactly right and so that
would get I'm trying to think of like
that would get wrapped up in the xlsx
format and would travel with the
document I'm try to think about the
reproducibility findability I'm sure
sure certainly yes we can capture this
providence that we captured into this
dot xlsx zip file and later on another
user can open it up and see that this is
the processing that that's been done on
this document and then the
sixty-four-thousand-dollar question is
what's going to make a scientist
to do this what's the motivation I mean
you know you've got economic I
understand the technical possibilities
there but it's the social that you know
it's fantastic i love the fact that my
experiment people who are sharing the
work flows but literally getting
scientists say okay I'm going to capture
you know the long tail of science that
done in this Excel spreadsheet you know
what and you have any thoughts on what's
going to motivate them to do that um
well certainly sometimes they do some
exploratory work on their analysis a day
later they forget what did I do so
essentially what what happens right now
is they have to redo the whole thing
well with this one it can save them time
because it recorded what they did and
they can just look at the visualization
say oh yeah that's what I did oh no this
doesn't work so i can i can modify it
and save it perhaps pass it on somebody
else or just keep it to myself if that's
the intent of the scientist this and
this is all under their control so i
think that's another way that they can
buy into this tool is it's all within
their control it's up to them if they
want to share it and it's up to them you
know how to use the tools so i think
being able to cut down on them having to
redo their analysis because I that's
what I've heard so far is they forgot
yes exactly they they spend a lot of
time just managing the data and not
really on the real science of thinking
about what's the ramification of this
finding you know what what does what's
the implication can see business
so that this is an approximation
performed of this data and then are
going to safety process and then hockey
this expert is processed
I physical or via the reproducibility
grandson is so yeah so that that will
become kind of like a lab procedure that
means of sharing a map
and perhaps I don't know maybe down the
road with editors they could require a
certain type of reproducibility and this
could be one of the things that
scientists can submit this is how i've
done my analysis on this data set a long
term I didn't mention this but I was
hoping I could do this with Excel and
then with other scientific tools too
then later on aggregate all that
information and then run the the topic
modeling on all that captured provenance
and I think that'll be really
interesting yeah well thank you very
much hazel here well no you've given me
a lot to think about hopefully the
people to watch this at some later point
the rolla will have a lot of ideas too i
can't i've got a list of 10 people i
think you should be talking to all right
that's all that's really inside
Microsoft and further pretty much
further afield as well oh good to hear
that thank you thank you very much thank
you